einen schönen guten abend und willkommen
zu heute live liebe zuschauer innen und
user innen ja die sprech pause bei der
anrede ihr wisst es vermutlich soll
bedeuten dass der begrüßen da alle
personen mit einschließen möchte in
seiner begrüßung also frauen männer aber
eben auch nicht binäre personen und
damit sind wir schon mitten drin im
thema denn es geht heute um die frage
braucht ist diese länder gerechte
sprache wie es auch heißt oder braucht
es diese sprache eben nicht und wir
diskutieren darüber gleich mit aminata
touré von den grünen vize präsidentin
des landtags von schleswig holstein die
sich für das verwenden von gender
gerechter sprache einsetzt und mit
christoph ploß bundestagsabgeordnete der
cdu und parteivorsitzender in hamburg
und er ist für ein verbot von gender
gerechter sprache in behörden schulen
und universitäten
bevor wir bei in die diskussionen mit
den politikern bzw der politikerin und
den politiker einsteigen wollen wir noch
mal das ergebnis uns angucken einer ja
zugegebenermaßen nicht repräsentative
kurzumfrage zu diesem thema die wir
heute in der mainzer innenstadt gemacht
haben
aufmerksam zu machen auf das thema finde
ich schon richtig aber
tick zu übertrieben
oftmals dargestellt ich finde es
unglaublich gut nämlich zurzeit sind nur
die männlichen person repräsentiert und
alle anderen seien halt einfach durch
das register ich merke aber noch dass
ich mich selbst einordnung schwer tue
und sobald ich habe auch merkel dass da
jemand irgendwie eben darauf achtet
achte ist auch sehr drauf weil ich dem
gegenüber auch den respekt natürlich
beweisen will sich sind sehr gut weil
ich einfach finde man sollte alle leute
einschließen und du doch kmw und solange
sich damit andere leute auch
eingeschlossen fehlen wie ich es gut und
warum nicht tja so weiter also diese
kurze umfrage kleine ergänzung von uns
es gab auch welche die das gender total
unsinnig finden die das aber so vor der
kamera nicht sagen wollten fangen wir
mal an mit frau turin noch einmal ganz
herzlich willkommen hier bei uns in der
sendung die meisten haben sich also
positiv geäußert inoffiziellen umfragen
es gibt eine aus dem jahr 2020 eine
insel umfrage da sagen allerdings auch
62% ländern sei unwichtig wie erleben
sie die debatte im alltag also ich
glaube es mit genau dank der stimmen von
zwängen oder verboten spricht aber ich
finde all diejenigen die sagen ich
möchte gerne denn dann in meiner sprache
und ich möchte mich mit dem thema
auseinandersetzen weil sprache eben auch
gesellschaft front warum sorgen die das
nicht tun und ich finde das höchst
problematisch und an die debatte so
führt dass man von verboten spricht weil
ich finde menschen zu verbieten eine
inklusive sprache zu benutzen ist
herr plus auch ihnen noch mal einen
schönen guten abend wir kommen gleich
nochmal auf die argumente zu sprechen
aber vor ort ändern sie denn eigentlich
im tagtäglichen gebrauch gar nicht also
auch nicht als privatperson
also ich sage zum beispiel bei anreden
liebe bürgerinnen und bürger aber ich
versuche sprache möglichst einfach zu
halten und mich auch verständlich
auszudrücken weil mir sehr wichtig ist
dass möglichst viele menschen an meiner
kommunikation als politiker teilhaben
können ich möchte keine kunstsprache an
den tag legen die nur sehr wenige im
land verstehen sondern die teilhabe an
kommunikationsprozessen auch über die
sprache halte ich persönlich für sehr
wichtig soweit ihre eingangs statement
wir wollen
hatte gleich vertiefen wollen uns aber
vorher noch mal sozusagen auf den
aktuellen stand der debatte bringen
lassen was ist eigentlich genauso
schwierig daran meine kollegin sarah
alaska hat sich dem thema nochmal
gewidmet ob sternchen unterstrich
doppelpunkt oder binnen-i varianten gibt
es viele 1 aber haben sie gemeinsam mit
ihnen sollen sich alle angesprochen
fühlen frauen männer und all jene die
sich einem dritten oder gar keinem
geschlecht zugehörig fühlen also nicht
binär sind einheitliche regeln gibt es
bisher nicht auch der rat für deutsche
rechtschreibung ein gremium aus
wissenschaft verlagen journalismus und
literatur hat sich bislang noch nicht
festgelegt
anders der duden der benutzt das
sternchen zwar nicht mieter sind hier
aber nur noch mehr und auch einige
behörden ländern inzwischen zum beispiel
die verwaltung der
schleswig-holsteinischen
landeshauptstadt kiel
anderswo wird gerade mitunter hitzig
diskutiert in hamburg etwa da würde der
cdu-landesverband das gendern in
behörden am liebsten verbieten
herr bloß die cdu in hamburg würde also
die gender gerechte sprache am liebsten
verbieten ob das juristisch möglich wäre
lassen wir jetzt mal dahin gestellt sein
aber jedenfalls bekämpfen sie das
vorhaben politisch und auch die unions
hochschul vereinigung rcds fordert ein
verbot warum diese heftige ablehnung
warum ein verbot also erst einmal möchte
ich klarstellen dass wir kein
grundsätzliches verbot fordern wir sagen
im privaten so jede person nach lust und
laune gendern können also wenn sie am
arm pro tisch mit ihrer frau die ändern
möchten sollen sie das natürlich gerne
tun und ich würde es deswegen auch
positiv formulieren wir fordern dass in
staatlichen einrichtungen wie schulen
die universitäten oder wie behörden die
deutsche grammatik gilt und die amtliche
deutsche rechtschreibung gilt ich finds
ehrlicherweise schon fast merkwürdig
dass wir darüber diskutieren
denn es muss doch eigentlich klar sein
dass staatliche einrichtungen sich an
die normen und regeln halten sollten die
wir uns auch als gesellschaft gegeben
haben
foto re wollen sie da gleich darauf
entgegnet ja sehr gerne also erstens
ändert man auch wenn man das generische
maskulinum verwendet das heißt ländern
ist halt nicht nur wenn man sozusagen
das sternchen oder benutzt sondern sie
denn dann halt einfach nur männlich und
meinen damit nur eine hälfte der
gesellschaft und dann ist der zweite
punkt auf die frage von sprache und
gesellschaft wie sie sich
weiterentwickelt und ich finde es schon
problematisch und sie haben die debatte
angestoßen dass man ein solches verbot
in einer staatlichen institution oder im
staatlichen city zu fahren möchte wobei
ich das wieder so erleben viele menschen
staatliche kastration arbeiten sagen wir
wollen gerne leitfragen wird zu haben da
gibt es keine zwänge da gibt es einfach
den wohnstandard zugucken wie kann man
sowas einheitlich gestalten und ich
finde es extrem ausschließen und
menschenrechtler sprachen nicht mit
einzubeziehen
bevor ich da muss ich widersprechen es
gibt einen sehr vielen universitäten
leitfäden für sogenannte gender gerechte
sprache und da wird den studenten
gedroht wenn sie nicht ändern dann
bekommen sie punkte abzug
und dass apple uns inakzeptabel wenn
frau story hier klar stellt dass sie das
für falsch halten dann wäre das schon
mal sehr begrüßenswert es erhält + ich
weiß dass 78 cdu noch der rcds diese
behauptung ganz oft auf stellen und
sagen dass man dadurch auch schlechtere
punkte bekommt aber ich habe vor kurzem
erste artikel der gestern rausgekommen
ist gewesen bei dem sie diese
behauptungen gar nicht aufstellen können
natürlich wird auch an universitäten die
stätten in dem die eben über
gesellschaft und fortschritt diskutieren
auch in leitfähigen formuliert und es
wird gesagt wie man es tun kann aber
wirklich zu behaupten und das belegen
das sind zwei unterschiedliche paar
schuhe und ich glaube dass wir als
gesellschaft uns weiterentwickeln und
ich habe unter anderem auch
sprachwissenschaften studiert deswegen
weiß ich auch dass sprache gesellschaft
formt und so zu tun als wäre das etwas
was stehenbleibt wir sprechen ja auch
nicht so wie im letzten jahr und darüber
im vorletzten jahrhundert und das ist
eine entwicklung die stattfindet und ich
glaube dass zivilgesellschaft aber auch
fortschrittlicher ist als politik ist
manchmal dass frau tory der begriff oder
der wunsch nach dem massaker noch immer
noch auf ganz gut los geht es hier zu
sehr durcheinander frau tor ideen
er griff leitfaden wir haben sie jetzt
gerade gebracht das würden sie
allerdings auch unterstützen
ich finde wenn man menschen freistellt
zu sagen wenn du lust hast
geschlechtergerechte sprache zu benutzen
dann kannst du es so und so machen warum
nicht ich spreche aber nicht von den
gesetzlichen verpflichtungen des tun zu
müssen oder von einem verbot ist nicht
zu tun zu dürfen das ist etwas was mir
tatsächlich ideologisch zu weit geht an
der stelle die mit dem vorschlag den die
cdu der an der stelle macht werden herr
prof
da möchte ich darf ich einmal zurück
fragen wir haben nämlich aufgrund der
debatte in den vergangenen tagen viele
studenten aus ganz deutschland
gender leitfäden zugeschickt in denen
mit denen ihnen angedroht wird dass die
punktabzüge wirkung bekommen wenn sie
nicht richtig ländern in ihren
hausarbeiten oder in ihren
abschlussarbeiten und jetzt würde von
frau touré einmal wissen halten sie das
für inakzeptabel und halten sie diese
auflagen für falsch oder unterstützen
sie diese länder leitfäden na ja die
frage kann ich ihn ja genauso auch
zurückstellen wenn sie sich für ein
verbot aussprechen sprechen sie sich
dafür aus dass wenn menschen
beispielsweise geschlechtergerechte
sprache verwenden dann auch
möglicherweise punktabzüge bekommen
sollten ich glaube man muss es einen
verden von verbuchung sondern dass man
möglichkeiten aufzeigt und sagt so
könnte man das machen
dafür spreche ich mich aus ich spreche
mich immer dafür aus dass man mögliche
menschen möglichkeiten aufzeigen und
sagt so kann man es machen wenn man denn
möchte aber dadurch darf kein nachteil
bestehen weder wenn man sich dagegen
ausspricht geschlechtergerechte sprache
zu verwenden noch wenn man sagt man
möchte nicht das generische maskulin
verbänden aber sie sprechen sich leider
und der stelle dafür aus nur das
generische maskulinen zu verwenden
das finde ich nicht mehr zeitgemäßen
tatsächlich frau tore herbst ganz kurz
ich mich wird sein dass wir uns
zumindest das ok hab bloß noch diesen
satz dann würde ich mich zumindest genau
ich würde dann vorschlagen er liebe frau
theorie dass wir uns zumindest auf einen
punkt verständigen dem wir beide teilen
können nämlich das ist kein gender zwang
und keine gender auflagen an
universitäten geben darf das in dem ich
jetzt auch ihren ausführungen und wenn
sie das hier auch so sagen dann wäre das
klasse weil da könnten wir auch
gemeinsam eine initiative starten ich
möchte aber noch mal kurz
gründen warum ich dafür bin dass in
staatlichen einrichtungen die deutsche
grammatik geht und die deutsche
rechtschreibung weil das die regeln sind
die wir uns als gesellschaft selbst
gegeben haben
so wie auch in anderen bereichen ist es
doch klar dass sich staatliche
einrichtungen auch an regeln halten
sollten also wenn ihr zum beispiel ein
erster klasse oder zweiter klasse der
unterstrich gelehrt wird in der anderen
das gender sternchen beim in der dritten
klasse dann das binnen muskel und in
anderen klassen dann wiederum das
generische maskulinum dann führt das
doch zu einer extrem verwirrung und dann
führt das dazu dass überhaupt keine
gemeinsamkeiten in der sprache mehr da
sind und das halten wir für falsch und
deswegen ist einfach ganz normal meine
forderungen wie sie auch in anderen
bereichen selbstverständlich ist dass
die regeln in staatlichen einrichtungen
gelten sollen aber ich freue mich sehr
dass sie zumindest den punkt
unterstützen das ist keine legende
auflagen den universitäten geben darf
und das nehmen wir glaube ich alle
nochmal applaus gibt auch mehr
widerspruch von frau kalorien
genau da haben sie mich falsch
verstanden weil ich bin noch gar nicht
dass wochen gemeinsame nenner kommen
müssen an der stelle weil nicht immer
das wird tatsächlich grund
unterschiedliche haltung zu diesem thema
haben
ich bin eben nicht dafür von verboten
oder von gesetzen zu sprechen den punkt
haben sie ausgemacht und ihn unterstütze
ich auch nicht durch unterstütze ist
wenn wir in unserer gesellschaft
debatten darüber führen wie hier
geschlechtergerechte sprache führen
können bei dem traum mit gemeint sind
bei dem auch menschen die interessent
die trans sind die unterschiedlichen
geschlechter haben auch in der sprache
gemeint ich habe die debatte ihrerseits
immer so wahrgenommen und auch in ihrer
partei wenn ich beispielsweise natürlich
mehr als angucken viele andere dass sie
sich vehement dagegen aussprechen
deswegen finde ich gar nicht dass wir an
der stelle einen gemeinsamen nenner
finden müssen weil ich eine dezidiert
andere haltung dazu habe genauso wie
meine partei an der stelle
also wir sind sehr froh dass ich eine
sehr lebendige debatte entscheiden
rothenbaum herb los ganz kurz erlauben
sie mir bitte dass sich die debatte noch
um eine weitere person erweitere denn
auch ihr parteikollege also auch in der
union ist das thema umstritten ihr
parteikollege
herr hans der ministerpräsident des
saarlandes hat sich geäußert und wir
wollen mal hören wie er sich in die
debatte einbringen wenn sie vor einer
gruppe von studierenden der
medizinischen fakultäten die teilweise
zu 90 prozent aus jungen frauen bestehen
nur in der männlichen form sprechen dann
geht ihnen plötzlich ein licht auf das
fühlt sich komisch an herpes er sagt das
fühlt sich komisch an
was entgegnen sie darauf er sagt auch
sinngemäß das ist für die union
wichtigeres gäbe als sprach vorschriften
zu machen hat er da recht
also ich finde sprache ist sehr wichtig
für den zusammenhalt unserer
gesellschaft und sprache ist ein
wichtiger teil unserer kultur und daher
ist natürlich eine debatte über sprache
auch sehr sehr wichtig und man sieht ja
auch an den vielen reaktionen dass das
ein thema ist was viele menschen bewegt
das ist das eine das andere ist dass es
schon ein unterschied gibt zwischen
einem grammatischen genuss und dem
geschlecht und das ist bei der debatte
auch ganz wichtig ich bin jetzt eine
person die vor der kamera steht trotzdem
würde wahrscheinlich niemand auf die
idee kommen zu sagen ich wäre kein mann
und daher muss man wirklich den
unterschied zwischen genuss und sex bei
dieser ganzen diskussion vielleicht auch
noch mal erklären
manchmal ist der deutschunterricht liegt
ja schon lange zurück aber wenn man
jetzt wirklich sagt zum beispiel die
person soll durch geändert werden wohin
soll das führen und für mich ist auch
noch ein weiterer punkt ganz ganz
wichtig gerade in staatlichen
einrichtungen sollte doch eine
kommunikation herrschen die eine
mehrheit im land vorzieht und die eine
mehrheit im land an den tag legt in
sportvereinen bei der freiwilligen
feuerwehr an erotischen da spricht doch
kaum jemand in der gender sprache und
sagt ich gehe jetzt zur italienerin oder
zum italiener sondern die meisten sagen
acht wir freuen uns morgen gehen wir zum
italiener und es spricht auch keiner von
arbeitnehmer- gender hicks innen
interessen und daher kann ich wirklich
nur noch mal daran appellieren dass
gerade die staatlichen einrichtungen
sich an regeln und normen halten sollten
vor allem auch eine
an den tag legen sollten die möglichst
wieder verstehen das ist mir auch
deswegen wichtig da zum beispiel
behindertenverbände darauf hinweisen
dass gerade menschen mit behinderungen
bei der künstlichen gender sprache
ausgeschlossen werden und auch das halte
ich für fatal wir brauchen eine sprache
die zusammenführt und die viele menschen
auch eine teilhabe an gesellschaftlichen
diskussion ermöglicht frau cora eine
sprache die zusammenführt und teilhabe
ermöglicht das klingt doch gut das kann
ja auch in ihren orden nichts schlechtes
sein
das ist auch nichts schlechtes und das
ist ja genau der anspruch den man hat
wenn man eine geschlechtergerechte
sprache verwendet die alle mit umfasst
und ich finde es übrigens auch immer ein
bisschen problematisch wenn man so tut
als würden menschen die in feuerwehr
verbänden sind die irgendwie am
stammtisch sitzen als wären sie nicht in
der lage solche debatten zu führen oder
so eine sprache zu benutzen
ich weiß nicht was rückreisen sie
unterwegs sind aber ich bin in sehr
unterschiedlichen diversen kreisen
unterwegs und da gibt es durchaus auch
menschen die diese sprache zu verwenden
egal was von abschluss singen haben die
garten hinter so formen deswegen finde
ich das immer ein bisschen schwierig
gesellschaftliche gruppen für die
eigenen interessen politisch zu
instrumentalisieren
ich glaube bei der frage von
geschlechter gesprächen sprach über
sprache insgesamt wenn ich das einmal
ausführen darf
da geht es dabei eben darum alle
menschen mit einzuschließen ich glaube
auch nicht dass man grundsätzlich sagen
kann dass alle menschen die eine
behinderung haben sich gegen eine
geschlechtergerechte sprache aussprechen
sondern dass es da unterschiedliche
positionen gibt so wie es eben bei
menschen mit behinderung auch einige
verwenden diese sprache andere wiederum
nicht
mir geht es im kern darum dass wir mit
unserer sprache natürlich zum ausdruck
bringen wo die ihr gesellschaftlichen
stück weit stehen
und der punkt ist natürlich auch sprache
ist ja nicht gottgegeben sprache ist
menschengemacht normen sind menschen
wenn du uns gesellschaftlich über solche
dinge austauschen ist es wichtig und gut
darüber zu sprechen normen können sich
verändern und sprache kann sich
verändern und das hat es immer gegeben
wird es auch immer geben und ich bin mir
sicher das ist ja dass alle in die
richtung bewegen
herr flowers da möchte ich aber auch
noch mal einen haken denn hier handelt
es sich ja nicht um eine natürliche
sprachentwicklung sondern das gegenteil
trat der viehhaltung gehalt handelt es
sich um einen orchestriert
eingriff einer minderheit in die sprache
die eine große mehrheit im land ablehnt
und nach repräsentativen umfragen und
nicht nach straßenumfragen lehnen immer
mehr menschen im land die gender sprache
ab das heißt die ablehnung ist sogar
noch gewachsen und das auch aus guten
gründen weil ich bin wirklich viel auch
in unterschiedlichen teilen der
gesellschaft unterwegs und kann ihnen da
wirklich nur sagen eine mehrheit im land
die benutzt nicht die gender sprache und
die möchte auch nicht dass ihre kinder
an den schulen eine falsche grammatik
lernen und forschen universitäten die
möchten nicht dass sie gezwungen werden
in jeder sprache ihre arbeiten zu
schreiben oder anträge zu formulieren
und auch viele ältere mitmenschen in
unserem land die sagen zu recht also
bitte für uns nicht so die deutsche
sprache diese wortungetüme die da
teilweise entstehen
die können wir nicht mehr nachvollziehen
und da kann ich nur all diesen menschen
sagen wie er als cdu wir stehen an ihrer
seite
ja das ist eine sehr interessante
position aber ich finde das schon
problematisch wenn sie sagen da gibt es
eine minderheit orchestriert dass eine
geschlechtergerechte sprache verwendet
werden soll
die meisten menschen die ich kenne die
sich mit sprache auseinandersetzen ja
die versuchen eben wege zu finden eine
inklusive gesellschaft zu schaffen und
machen dabei spiele und auch von
minderheiten so zu sprechen als hätten
sie nicht das recht auf ihren interessen
durchzubringen er bloß finde ich auch
nicht problematisch ja es gibt eine
mehrheit unserer gesellschaft sagt sie
möchte diese sprache nicht verwenden
ich finde das funktional und dann sollen
sie das nicht tun aber der einer
minderheit wiederum und das ist ihr
politischer vorschlag an der stelle zu
verbieten diese sprache zu verwenden
wiederum das ist doch etwas rückständig
meiner meinung nach und deswegen bin ich
der meinung wir können diese debatte
führen aber über verbote zu sprechen
welche sprache benutzt werden soll
finde ich problematisch sie haben vorhin
gesagt dass es für sie um eine
grammatikalische dann aber gegen die
gender leitfäden an universitäten seien
dann erwarte ich mit dieser mit dieser
haltung die sie hier zeigen erwarte ich
dass sie jetzt sagen keine rinder
leitfäden universitäten jetzt wird es
aber sehr deutlich dass es ihm gar nicht
so sehr um eine grammatikalische die
heute geht sondern schieben auch immer
eine politische debatte und ich sage
ihnen das noch einmal wiederholt meine
position ist wenn an öffentlichen
institutionen menschen das interesse
daran
diese sprache zu verwenden warum kann
man nicht einen zweiteiligen leitfaden
dort rein geben das ist ein sehr
liberaler ansatz den pakete ich den
anderen leid reden von der prüfern an an
studenten das ist geht es um gender
leitfäden für hausarbeiten die müssten
sie doch ablehnen nach dem was sie sagen
die lehne ich nicht ehrlich gesagt sie
kriegen punktabzug wenn sie nicht ändern
das ist doch ein gender zwang den haben
sie eben abgelehnt ich hab' ich sage
ihnen nochmal sie sagen immer wieder
dass das sozusagen eine meiner situation
ist die allem entschieden dann ein
universitäten sozusagen usus ist es mag
diese sterne geben ich finde es nicht
richtig ich finde es sehr wichtig
menschen die möglichkeit zu geben eine
geschlechtergerechte sprache zu
verwenden
nichtsdestotrotz bin ich gegen ihren
vorschlag von verboten zu sprechen wenn
es um sprache geht weil sprache sich
weiterentwickelt und eine inklusive
sprache etwas ist was ich begrüße herbst
darf ich gerade noch mal ein haag und
daher sogar schon mal positiv dass sie
sagen die gender leitfäden und den
gender zwang an universitäten darf es
nicht geben dass es zumindest der nenner
auf den wir uns beide verständigen
können das ist doch schon mal was gutes
ich bin für leitfäden in staatlichen
institutionen bei denen man die
möglichkeit hat gender gerechte sprache
zu verwenden wenn man das möchte ich bin
nicht gegen leitfäden nur dass wir das
noch mal aber sie ein echter punktabzug
an universitäten dagegen würden sie mit
mir vorgehen wenn irgendwo steht es gibt
punktabzug wenn man nicht ändern da war
diese realität cap los die können sie
leider nicht beweisen und deswegen ist
das ein problem für mich wenn wir die
messen ich habe viele studenten die sich
bei mir gemeldet haben was ist welche
ihr diese leitfäden zu schicken und
wollen wir dann zusammen uns darum
kümmern und sagen liebe universität
diesen gender leitfaden dürfte bitte
nicht verwenden denn herum dass züge für
studenten die nicht ändern sind
inakzeptabel können wir zusammen machen
schlagwerk und auch bezahlen
wenn wir uns darauf einigen können dass
sie keine politischen debatten führen
bei denen sich ein bote von
geschlechtergerechte sprache führen
wollen und das in staatlichen
institutionen verbieten wollen dann
können dann gerne nochmal drüber
sprechen aber ich glaube zudem kommt bin
ich und das ist aber eigentlich der kern
der debatte um den es geht ist dem so ja
klar wir können doch zumindest schon mal
uns auf einen punkt verständigen
bei dem wir uns einig sind das wäre doch
von hinten gut wenn man
als politisch zusammenarbeiten würde
müssten wir ja gar nicht an der stelle
weil ich würde mich fiel er auf den
punkt einigen wollen keine verbote
sprachen zu fordern wenn wir uns auf den
punkt einigen können dann können wir
weiter sprechen
also wir erhalten mal an der stelle fest
dass es ein konstruktives
gesprächsangebot gibt von ihnen beiden
aufeinander da noch mal zuzugeben bzw
das gespräch zu suchen
das würden wir sehr begrüßen wir haben
nicht mehr allzu viel zeit nur noch vier
minuten heraus ich habe mir noch mal die
frage gestellt auch in der vorbereitung
auf die sendung ob sozusagen wir beide
als männer die ja auch bei egal welchem
sprachgebrauch immer mit angesprochen
sind ob wir das nachvollziehen können
das anliegen dass die andere seite hat
oder ob das etwas ist was wir allein
emotional gar nicht so richtig
beurteilen können wie erleben sie das
also erstmal ist laut dem
repräsentativen umfragen auch eine
mehrheit bei den frauen gegen die gender
sprache und lehnt es vor allem ab das
ist in staatlichen einrichtungen ein
gender zwang gibt daher bin ich auch auf
der seite einer mehrheit der frauen in
unserem land im übrigen hat das thema
gender sprache sehr wenig mit
gleichberechtigung zu tun denn dann
müsste ja zum beispiel in der türkei
oder müssten in ungarn müssen wir fast
schon ein klares matriarchat haben
dort werden die nutzlose sprachen
gesprochen und daran sieht man doch dass
das gender nun wirklich mit dem
wichtigen anliegen der
gleichberechtigung nichts zu tun hat was
mir viel wichtiger ist wenn wir über die
gleichberechtigung von männern und
frauen sprechen das ist zum beispiel
eine gleiche bezahlung und die
vereinbarkeit von familie beruf und
daher lege ich meine initiativen auch er
in diese richtung und setze da ein
schwerpunkt drauf aber die gender
sprache hat nun wirklich mit der
gleichberechtigung von mann und frau gar
nichts zu tun
foto re das halte ich für einen ganz
wesentlichen punkt inwieweit hat die
sprache tatsächlich einfluss auf die
gesellschaftlichen verhältnisse
herr poß hat die türkei angesprochen
dort ist natürlich die politische
situation der frauen auch wenn es sprach
ich vielleicht besser aussieht weil es
eben dieses maskuline kinos in der form
nicht gibt aber ist die politische
situation deswegen ja nicht besser also
in wie weit würden sie sagen ist die
sprache vielleicht da auch in ihrer
funktion überschätzt
ich glaube dass es keinen sinn macht zu
glauben dass es in der frage von
gleichberechtigung nur um sprache geht
aber es gibt ganz viele studien
sozialpsychologische studien die
deutlich machen das ist eigentlich
irrelevant ist ob man eine
geschlechtergerechte sprache verwendet
oder nicht ob frauen und mädchen sich
vorstellen können bestimmte berufe zu
machen oder nicht das sprach natürlich
daran geknüpft ist und noch einmal
jetzt verstehe ich nicht versuchen sie
den letzten satz bitte noch mal zu
wiederholen konnten sie gerade nicht
verstehen es ist ja nicht so dass die
forderungen um geschlechtergerechte
sprache oder das verbot darum von
denjenigen angeführt worden ist die sich
für eine gleichberechtigte gesellschaft
einsetzen ganz im gegenteil
das kam ja gerade von sibiu
konservativer seite an der stelle bei
der frage um geschlechtergerechtigkeit
kann sprache ein element sein aber über
der frage von geschlechtergerechtigkeit
gibt es eben auch um die fragen wie zum
beispiel schutz vor gewalt es geht um
fragen von gleicher bezahlung es geht um
die frage von familie und beruf beides
vereinzelt können dass das alles punkte
die man politisch natürlich immer wieder
diskutiert und die wir übrigens als
grüne in unserem wahlprogramm mit drin
stehen haben und gerne darüber
diskutieren wollen wir haben die debatte
um gleich geschlechtergerechte sprache
muss angeführt das kam von der cdu aber
vielleicht liegt es auch daran dass wir
die vorschläge für
geschlechtergerechtigkeit von der cdu ja
noch gar nicht kennen weil es auch kein
wahlprogramm gibt an der stelle
aber ich bin gerne bereit dazu auch in
den nächsten wochen monaten weiterhin
gerne darüber zu diskutieren wie er
einigen schlechter gerechtigkeit
hinbekommen können weil das ist das ziel
um das es geht los ist es 548 sie haben
einen anschlusstermin wollen sie noch
darauf antworten oder bitten sie mich
die sendung zu beenden
nein da ein punkt finde ich ist nochmal
ganz wichtig weil der grundlegend für
viele andere gesellschaftliche debatten
steht mir macht gewisse sorge dass die
grünen und einige andere im linken
politischen spektrum die menschen immer
stärker nach faktoren wie dem geschlecht
nach der hautfarbe nach der sexuellen
orientierung einteilen das merken wir
auch bei der diskussion über die gender
sprache und ich finde auf diese faktoren
darf es doch gar nicht ankommen jeder
mensch ist gleich und wenn wir eine wir
gesellschaft werden wollen dann dürfen
noch nicht immer die unterschiede und
das trennende betont werden dann sondern
dann brauchen wir gemeinsamkeiten dann
brauchen wir brücken zwischen
unterschiedlichen gesellschaftlichen
gruppierungen und deswegen bin ich auch
dafür dass wir die jetzige deutsche
grammatik stärken die norm die wir uns
gegeben haben
die sprache wird sich immer
weiterentwickeln aber eine mehrheit im
land muss auch dahinter stehen und muss
die sprache auch verstehen können und
verstehen wollen
und daher kann ich nur noch mal sagen
ich wehre mich dagegen dass eine kleine
minderheit im land versucht eine
sprachpolizei zu installieren oder
versucht eine sprache die eine mehrheit
ablehnt gegen viele andere im land
durchzudrücken
ich finde dass wenn ich darf da einmal
noch trainieren ja bitte kurz ratlos ich
möchte ich es einmal ganz ehrlich und
deutlich sagen und dass sich das sehr
schockierend findet wie sie
diskriminierungserfahrungen und umdrehen
weil der punkt bei einer frage von
geschlechtergerechte sprache oder
diskriminierungsfreie sprache oder die
frage von welcher sprache benutzen wir
die nicht diskriminierend ist die haben
nicht minderheiten ist sondern es ist in
der regel die mehrheit weil man merkt an
der stelle dass sie gar kein gefühl
dafür haben wie es ist wenn menschen
diskriminierungserfahrungen machen und
darum geht es in frage von
diskriminierungsfreie sprache und das
ist das politische ziel dass man an der
stelle hat zu sagen wie schaffen wir es
eigentlich minderheit in 12 unserer
gesellschaft zu akzeptieren durch
sprache und durch tragen so das war das
letzte statement von frau to rehab los
wenn sie wollen noch eine kurze replik
dann ist das also ich kann nur noch mal
sagen es ist ganz ganz wichtig dass man
sich in andere menschen hineinversetzen
und ich würde mir mehr empathie in
unserer gesellschaft insgesamt wünschen
und daher ist es auch wirklich so
wichtig dass wir nicht versuchen jede
einzelne gesellschaftliche gruppe in der
gesellschaft in der sprache abzubilden
das auch doch genau dafür dass man sich
auch immer stärker selber nur noch über
diese gruppe definiert und in einem
kollektiv einordnet also zum beispiel
wir betonen
und sie betont als grüne den starken
unterschied zwischen mann und frau
zwischen heterosexuellen und
homosexuellen
und ich finde auf so etwas darf es gar
nicht ankommen wir brauchen gleiche
rechte wir brauchen gleiche chancen für
alle menschen in unserer gesellschaft
das ist mein anliegen ich möchte eine
chancen gesellschaft schaffen
aber ich möchte nicht immer das
trennende betonen oder das was unsere
gesellschaft spaltet und daher kann ich
nur noch mal dafür werben eine
spalterische gender sprache die brauchen
wir in deutschland in keiner weise und
wir sollten eine sprache wirklich an den
tag legen die eine mehrheit im land
bevorzugt und die vor allem den meisten
menschen im land
auch teilhabe ermöglicht und dafür werde
ich auch im bundestagswahlkampf werben
ich merke es trenc autor aber wir müssen
jetzt an dieser stelle einen punkt
machen vielen dank ich denke ihre beiden
standpunkte sind deutlich geworden und
wie gesagt es gibt noch weitere termine
herr plus foto ri vielen dank für die
zeit dass sie sich heute abend diese
zeit genommen haben es ging um die
deutsche sprache
der duden kennt das gender sternchen er
selbst benutzt ist allerdings noch nicht
es liegt also noch einiges an arbeit vor
der gruppe die sich darum bemühen möchte
dass sich das ändert an euch vielen dank
fürs mitmachen ich habe einige
kommentare natürlich gelesen ich konnte
allerdings ihr habt das gemerkt ich
hatte nicht die zeit sie daran zu nehmen
denn die debatte war sehr lebendig und
der moderator fast schon überflüssig
ich habe also versucht möglichst wenig
eingegriffen wie ihr gemerkt haben
werdet trotzdem vielen dank fürs mit
schauen jedenfalls und auch fürs
mitmachen und beim nächsten mal dann
wieder mehr raum für kommentare und für
fragen versprochen bis dann uns auf
wiedersehen schönen abend